[Music]
hi everybody i'm leah and i'm nikita and
welcome to the data cloud live demo
if you're just joining us from this
morning's keynote and spotlight you
heard some of the latest innovations we
launched earth engine spark on google
cloud postgres sql interface for spanner
and vertex ai workbench all to help
organizations solve their most complex
data-driven challenges
in this live demo we're going to take
complex fragmented data systems and
simplify them bringing together data on
a massive scale to explore a real-world
scenario for climate and supply chain
analytics in order to do this we're
gonna need the whole data team say hi
everyone
hello i'm brad
hi i'm derek
now a quick reminder this demo is truly
live and you can engage with us directly
so ask questions say hi in the chat
window and hit those emojis
i think i see some coming in now i see
lots of hearts and fire a lot of people
saying hello in the chat thanks everyone
for joining us today
so if you can't see the emojis or the
chat just go back to the next event
website and click on the blue join the
interactive experience button
okay
let's have a little fun with this
today you're actually joining us for our
weekly stand up at symbol superstore a
fictional u.s based grocery chain
focused on sourcing from local producers
like many different industries we need
to bring together disparate data sources
to build resilience
specifically for us drought in the
western u.s has impacted our producers
and our supply chain has been disrupted
with decreased shipments week over week
we need to better understand how to
manage inventory and to prevent
stockouts and ensure we can scale in
both how we analyze information and how
we run our transactions
all right team so to address the supply
and scale challenges that nikita just
mentioned we have four different
workloads
first i'm going to evaluate the best
climate information to identify at-risk
producers
then brad will mature our data pipelines
to transform that data next derek will
dig into scaling our transaction
processing and finally nikita will show
how we're gaining new insights by
evolving our data science capabilities
let's get into it and let's keep hearing
from all of you out there our data pros
leah you're up first great thanks nikita
so in order to gain insight into our
supply chain first i need to evaluate
the risks so i'm focusing on figuring
out how drought impacts the very source
of our grocery products
and to do this i turned to google's
platform for earth science data and
analytics earth engine which has a huge
catalog of satellite images for things
like climate weather croplands and much
more
there's currently over like 50 petabytes
of data in the catalog
plus more and more images are added each
day
so let me just go ahead and bring up
this cool little application that i
built using the earth engine code editor
so i can walk you through the three data
sets we'll be using today
first is going to be crop data from the
usda nass program which i can grab right
from the public data catalog by
searching
so this data set is going to contain one
image of the us for each year going back
all the way to 1997.
and each 10 meter pixel in this image
has actually been assigned a crop type
let me just close out of this here bring
you back to my app so the second data
set contains the outline of agricultural
fields and we're going to use earth
engine to assign each one of these
fields the crop type that is most
prevalent among the cells that cover it
so in this view that i'm showing right
here the pink fields are alfalfa and the
dark green fields are almonds leah these
visuals are super super helpful but can
we export this data for analysis in
other environments yep i'm actually
going to push this into cloud storage
and bigquery in just a sec but first i
want to add in some additional signals
on drought
so the third data set that i'm using is
a collection of both short and long term
drought indicators meaning that we can
see what drought looks like for each
field over time
now using data sets like these does
require some deep subject matter
expertise
so special thanks to our real world
partners at climate engine who build
solutions on top of earth engines api
helping organizations ground their
analytics projects with scientifically
accepted methodologies
okay so you just saw how we use
geospatial data and i want to know how
you use it in your analysis so go ahead
and answer that poll so we can see
all right everyone so with these layers
in place we can start exploring drought
risk
let me just go ahead and zoom to this
field
and here i'm going to show an almond
orchard northeast of modesto california
and what we're looking at is the
long-term drought indicator so this
orange tint that you're seeing means
that this field has experienced pretty
high levels of drought over the last
five years
now if i go ahead and just zoom out a
bit
we can actually see that the entire
central valley in california is pretty
drought stressed
so my last step was to calculate drought
risk for each of the fields i showed
before and this will tell us which farms
and produce types are potentially at
risk for not meeting customer demand
which is just one consideration to
inform symbols resilient strategy
better yet we can incorporate the
geography data with other spatial stuff
like store and customer locations that
are already inside of bigquery
and anyone who knows me knows that i
love bigquery if you agree let me see in
the emojis
all right so the code editor has been
great for interacting with earth engine
but making these calculations at scale
requires a different approach
so i went ahead and created earth engine
tasks for batch processing to run these
calculations over all the data in five
day increments for the past 10 years
i also set up a cloud function to run
every five days going forward so that
will always have fresh data
now just as a quick recap we jumped into
earth engine to evaluate earth science
data that indicates climate risk for our
farm fields
now we'll have fresh drought data
available in cloud storage
so just think of the power of
integrating huge amounts of specialized
data giving us a complete picture of
supply risk for our business
oh and i think i can see the poll
results coming in now
it looks like lots of people are using
geospatial data for all different kinds
of things and if your answer wasn't in
the poll just go ahead and let us know
in the chat
so next up brad will transform and push
this data into bigquery for geospatial
analysis with our existing data
so brad over to you
okay that was pretty cool leah thanks
all right
so to gain more insight into how drought
is impacting production my main focus
has been building out the data
transformation pipeline to push farm
field drought indicators from cloud
storage into bigquery
speaking of batch processing as you know
to assist with inventory management
price optimization and product
assortment we use spark to standardize
our large scale data processing and we
use google cloud data proc as our
long-running clusters
for you data pros out there we'd love to
know how you're using spark today so let
us know while i go ahead and pull up the
cloud console
so here is a data proc cluster we
currently use to schedule pi spark jobs
and here i'm connected to a jupiter
notebook running on the same cluster
with some pi spark code this code is
typical boilerplate code you'd write to
do basic data transformations in this
case we are processing the earth engine
files from cloud storage performing type
checking and mapping to ensure proper
ingestion into bigquery using the spark
bigquery connector
hey brad so this is pretty cool but i
think having a batch workflow that's
scheduled on a continuously running
cluster seems like it can be kind of
wasteful so is there any way we can make
this more efficient
that's a fair point leah there is still
some overhead in management here and for
hardened batch cases like this it would
be preferred to have these jobs run on
their own discrete resources
but good news with the new serverless
option for dataproc we can submit a pi
spark job without spinning up any
infrastructure these auto magic
capabilities i can spend more depth time
writing code and less time on managing
infrastructure
all right brad first off i'm pretty sure
that you just set me up for that and
second you definitely made up that word
automagic
yeah can i get the emoji love for
that anyway i'll now go ahead and export
this notebook to a python file using nb
convert
okay and next uh let's go and use the
cloud sdk to submit a serverless price
mark job we can use the dataproc api and
call batches to submit a serverless job
so i'm showing you here a pi spark job
but i can also submit spark jobs written
in scala java r or sql
with auto provision and auto scale no
infrastructure configuration is needed
this helps those less familiar with how
to fine tune their smart jobs to utilize
its powerful distributed data processing
model with these capabilities there's no
need to manually create and tune
clusters
so once i've submitted the job i can
show it listed in the serverless spark
console and i can click on the job to
view its logs
now serverless spark takes about a
minute or so to auto provision the
resources as well as start writing out
log output so what i'll go ahead and do
here is show you the log output from a
completed job that i ran earlier
so if we click in here we can see okay
so i added some print statements into
this job and here it's showing me that
there's some short term drop data that's
processed some long term drought data
and then some geographical data as well
now in addition to this i can also show
you the spark history server which is
where the more details of the spark job
itself will be
outputted once the job has been
completed so we can go back and debug
and then additionally we can also gain
access to metadata via dataproc
metastore
now in addition to all of this we are
also looking into a new solution for
creating long-running clusters or a
place where our infrastructure team can
manage dataproc clusters
now fortunately we feel that spark on
gke fits our use case and lets us
utilize our existing gke infrastructure
so clearly it's been a busy week for me
using spark serverless to create
pipelines to push drought data into
bigquery but the efficiency improvements
will gain by not needing to manage
cluster overhead will be worth it
now you can let me know in the chat if
you're as excited about spark
server-less as i am
okay let's see how everyone's using
spark today
looks like notebooks are pretty popular
oh and automation through airflow that's
cool too
okay great thanks so much brad so now
that we have greater insight into supply
risks we need to scale our transaction
systems to handle more orders and allow
us to understand the potential business
impact of these climate risks while
hopefully lowering costs
so this brings me to derek our dba
derek you've been focusing on this
effort so can you let us know where
you're at today
yeah absolutely leah
we have a new grocery chain that has
struggled to maintain their on-prem
databases as they've grown
there's an opportunity to solve their
underlying scaling problems with cloud
spanner
i spent the last few weeks validating
spanner's ability to scale and the ease
of maintenance while keeping strong
consistency for this point of sale
workload
i migrated some of the new change stores
to spanner already using granular
instant sizing i only provisioned a
portion of a spanner node to handle the
required load
as we move the remainder of stores we
can easily scale up without downtime or
app changes
quick question derek we've been really
focused on reducing the cost and
complexity of building scalable
applications so i'm wondering how does
adding spanner impact that effort
yeah that's a great question nikita
one way we've been doing this in other
environments is to standardize on
postgres
postgres is a well established open
source database with an active ecosystem
that our development and ops teams are
already familiar with
i tried to get the team to add an
elephant emoji so y'all could show some
love for postgres
but anyway
spanner just announced a poster sql
interface this gives us the benefits of
spanner without having to completely
retrain our application teams
having a standard api for our data will
help us maintain velocity for new
features
even as our database needs evolve here
let me show you
so i've connected into
our spanner instance using the psql
command line tool
from here i can explore the schema just
like i would any other database
any other postgres database
you can see that the both the postgres
data type and the spanner data type is
available to the information schema
so
this will make it familiar to anyone who
already knows postgres
awesome thanks derek this is really cool
i'm really looking forward to the
scalability that this is going to bring
our team
absolutely
and as a quick summary i highlighted how
to spanner allows us to get started
small and scale as needed using granular
instant sizing
and how the new postgresql interface
reduces friction for our teams already
familiar with postgres
nikita and leah you can treat the
existing data as golden and i'll keep
onboarding more stores
nikita i believe you need this data for
some of the big query analysis you were
working on
you've been busy figuring out how to
evolve our ability to make sense of all
this data can you show us how that works
yes absolutely i was hoping that you'd
ask so to ensure that we're managing
stock to meet customer demand my focus
this week was on evolving our data
science capabilities for exploratory
analysis
i combined the transactional data that
derek's been working on with the drought
data that leah and brad pushed into
bigquery
this way we can gain insight into which
products are most at risk of not meeting
customer demand
so my first step was to integrate all of
our transactional data within bigquery
primarily using federation with cloud
sql and spanner
this provides a unified environment for
aggregation and analysis where we can
join transactions back to producer
details and the associated drought risk
scores
now
as you all know we recently migrated to
vertex ai workbench
which has really really helped with our
basic compute and resource management
quick question nikita is vertex ai
workbench a notebook for vertex ai that
is an excellent question derek vertex ai
workbench contains recently updated
managed notebooks which bring forth more
integrated data engineering capabilities
into our data science environments so we
can ingest and analyze data and deploy
and manage ml models all from one spot
now let me show you a little bit about
what this looks like after i provisioned
a new managed notebook my first task was
to analyze the demand on the high volume
skus and for that i used the bigquery
connector to view and query the sales
data
with vertex ai workbench i can inspect
bigquery metadata preview tables and
automate basic sql construction entirely
from my notebook environment
okay
it's my turn on the emojis i want to see
the fire emoji from all the data
scientists out there who are as excited
as i am about being able to access
bigquery from the notebook interface
i'm not the only one
hey nikita hold on sorry to interrupt
your emoji fest but i see you're working
out of the lakes project but are able to
pin other projects you have access to
like the ops project is that new
yes that's correct brad vertex ai
workbench actually enables me to
interact with all services via my own
identity
the bigquery plugin also provides some
templated code to help build out queries
and project results to a pandas data
frame
so here we can see oh looks like i just
need to refresh
um sorry about that team i'm just going
to refresh my jupiter lab instance here
i guess i had it open for too long and i
guess while nikita is doing that like
who uses jupiter now let's see the fire
emoji is lighting up
i see so now
i personally use it a lot in my day
today all right thank you so perfect now
you can see a simple view of all
transactions by the day of week
and vertex workbench actually also
allows me to launch different kernels
entirely in the same instance so brad i
think you were working out of a peice
perk notebook earlier is that correct
yeah so dataproc clusters are also
supported as a backend as a part of
spark on google cloud we can access all
supported kernels on the cluster
including price park
well for my analysis i just needed a
python kernel so let me show you what's
going on in this notebook and what i've
been up to this week
you can see here that i've done a deep
dive into the data i've plotted the
transaction volume i've created a heap
map of purchase counts across various
departments and i've also plotted the
short-term drought index across various
crop types like corn dry beans pears and
rice
but my last task and the most important
task was to map skus to suppliers and
calculate a risk score based on the
aggregate field data
so to do this i started with our mapping
table which you can see a sample of
right here
this helped me to determine which farm
fields actually source ingredients for a
particular sku
and then i calculated a weighted risk
score that takes into account each
product's demand and the associated
farm's overall drought risk and you can
see each of these measurements in this
data frame right here
ultimately this score will help us to
prioritize managing items where we're
most at risk of not meeting customer
demand
so as a quick summary i used vertex ai
workbench managed notebooks to connect
back to data accessible from bigquery
and create a weighted risk score for
each one of our products combining both
climate and demand data
leah i went ahead and put all this back
into bigquery just to keep it
centralized
awesome thanks so much nikita that risk
score is going to be huge in helping our
team understand supply risk
so to make sure the broader team has a
trusted view of all this information i
started incorporating everything into a
looker dashboard
now with looker we define our metrics
like average risk using look ml lookers
data model and looker uses this to
compile sql queries and send them back
to bigquery on our behalf so that our
non-technical users can explore the
results of these data efforts
so let me show you this dashboard that
i've been working on and first off you
can see this custom map layer that i use
to visualize drought risk across farm
regions in the west
and we're able to take advantage of
bigquery's geospatial functions and
drill from this aggregate view all the
way to producer or even grocery product
level
let me show you so i'll drill to field
id
and then i can jump right into lookers
explore to bring in some more fields
like maybe i want to specifically look
at products that are at risk in this
region where we're quickly expanding
making all this data accessible to the
broader team is really important so can
we make sure that the marketing team is
aware of this so that they know how to
hold off on coupons or advertisements
for these products yeah actually we can
set up a schedule from looker so that
the regional marketing teams are always
notified if new products seem to go at
risk
so putting this all together we used
earth engine to process new earth
science data signals we use spark to
efficiently transform geospatial data
and push drought indicators into
bigquery
spanner to scale our transaction systems
ensuring we have the infrastructure to
handle future growth
and vertex ai workbench plus looker
backed by the power of bigquery to
evolve our data science capabilities and
surface important trends back to key
decision makers
so with integrations across these
services anyone is able to explore and
take action on insights that combine
climate data and transactions
now we can understand where products may
go out of stock due to increasing
drought conditions
and identify areas to build resilience
against changes in our climate so with
this geospatial information we're given
a whole new set of data so that we can
not only be considerate of our customers
but also find ways to be more
considerate of our planet
and with that it looks like we're right
about at time so thank you so much for
joining us today as we've shown how
google cloud can offer a world-class
experience for creating a scalable
unified data platform
and a special thanks to my colleagues
nikita for showing us vertex ai
workbench
derek for introducing us to spanner and
its postgres interoperability and brad
for walking us through spark on google
cloud and thank you leah for showing us
looker and earth engine
last but certainly not least thank you
all out there so much for your
engagement we love those emojis and
seeing all of your comments in the chat
so stay tuned for our live q a which is
going to cover everything from our
spotlight through this demo
thank you thanks everyone thanks bye
you